foreign
good morning and welcome to this
licensing act subcommittee
it's the the 22nd of april 2022 at 10
o'clock um this committee has been
called to hear an application in respect
of a new premises license for
the wood road site at hawley park wood
road
wool pit
briefly explained that the procedure
there will be a report
given by the the licensing officer
followed by
representations made by the parties
starting with the the applicant
there will be an opportunity once the
representation has been made to ask
questions on the representation
from the the designated uh speakers
then the
the objectives or those representations
on the application will also have an
opportunity to have their their say
there are several representations made
in writing they have all been considered
and will be considered as part of the
application but you have two
designated
speakers who will speak on your your
behalf again there'll be an opportunity
for questions from from all parties
when everybody's had their say and the
applicant will have the final word when
they sum up
we'll be a private session for the the
members of myself as legal advisor to
consider the application and make a
determination hopefully today
there are some preliminary procedures we
need to go through and this is a formal
committee
so what i will do now is hand over to
the the chair of the subcommittee who is
councillor kathy guthrie who is the
chair of the full licensing and
regulatory committee and therefore is
chairing this subcommittee today so over
to you
thank you very much indeed and welcome
to this uh
committee meeting today who's whistling
is there an issue sorry i hope you can
hear me
um
some domestic arrangements the council
members of the public and press may
record film photograph or broadcast this
meeting when the public and press are
not lawfully excluded
any member of the public who attend a
meeting and wishes to be filmed should
advise
which is to be filmed should advise the
committee partner i think which is not
to be filmed should advise the committee
clerk
so i hope you're all happy with that so
far can i remind you of the domestic
arrangements toilets are situated
opposite the lifts outside the meeting
room water is available outside the
meeting room if the fire alarm sounds
leave the building immediately via the
fire exit and make your way to the
assembly point which is ipswich town
football ground
follow the signs directing you to the
fire exit at each end of the floor do
not
enter the atrium which is the ground
floor area and walkways
if you are in the atrium at the time of
the alarm follow the signs to the
nearest fire exit
use the stairs and not the lifts do not
re-enter the building until told it is
safe to do so
i need to do this please switch off all
mobile phones or turn them to silent
so apologies for
absence none receive chair thank you
are there any declarations of interest
by councillors
counselor flatman
thank you chair um i'd just like um
everyone to know that i'm
lecture at west suffolk college i teach
events so basically we do use once a
year
holly barnes venue
and um
it
our students could be working there at
any time obviously this has no you know
bearing on decisions here today but i
just thought if anybody had seen me
there with students you would understand
why
thank you thank you i hope everybody can
hear can everybody hear clearly thank
you yes
so i will do the introductions obviously
myself i'm kathy guthrie i'm the chair
councillor dave muller at the end and
councillor julie flatman
we also have our legal advisor nigel de
liu
we have our licensing officer k sanders
good morning
and kerry chandler good morning morning
and our governance officer karen sayer
behind us and the member support officer
mandy smith who's busy pedaling
nightmare to get our electronics out so
this can go out to the public
so
may i ask um the applicants to introduce
yourselves and if you're representative
so mr williams would you introduce
yourself
yes you don't have to stand up i'm
robert williams
the
managing director of the applicant which
you will notice is not myself but hawley
park limited
who own
all the historic property
and land at hawley park
my
colleague is um
mrs martin silkstone
who is one of our balm
venue team
uh hawley park barn is a
thriving
you'll get the opportunity to say that's
just introducing yourselves if you
wouldn't mind please
and
she's here not so much to answer
questions but she is um
the person who looks after all our pr
and social media
so will you be making any comment during
the proceedings
not unless required because robert
williams needs assistance right and
that's in order thank you very much
indeed thank you for that mr silkster
so can i ask you mr williams have you
had receipt of the procedure report and
copies of all the representations
yes i have had the report the document
pack yes
thank you
now may i ask the other people to
introduce themselves who um will be
speaking on behalf of the spokesperson
julia ewan is that your good self
uh yes julia ewan's uh a well-known
spelling mistake in these hallowed halls
i'm usually called evans
i beg you please it's fine no don't
worry you got it right
um i checked i'm chair of woolpit parish
council welcome thank you and you'll be
speaking on behalf of the parish council
yes
and then we have tracy kettle
good morning
good morning um my name is tracy kettle
and i'm a resident of wood road opposite
wally park and you will be speaking on
behalf of the residents yes thank you
very much indeed and um joss roper was
unable to attend is that correct yeah
all right oh i beg your pardon but you
won't be speaking no that's that's i i
understand got it now thank you very
much
so
um talking to all parties um anybody
wishing to withdraw the application or
representation
mr williams no
no
and um
tracy kettle you don't wish to withdraw
anything right thank you
so my question now is to the licensing
officer have there been any requests
from the parties for permission to call
witnesses
no care
thank you
half the parties indicated they wish to
present documentary or other material no
chair thank you
so i'll ask each of you in turn um how
long do you think it will take you to
present your case please
i put on 10 to 15 minutes on the sheet
i hope it won't take longer than that
right
and
going to julia how long do you think
you'll take your presentation please um
i would hope only 10 minutes 10 minutes
and tracy if i can call you that by your
first name 10 minutes
thank
you so we now move to the hearing so the
licensing officer will present the
report and summarize the matter under
consideration so we've all got copy well
we've got copies of that um do we have
it online for the public to follow or
not
so it will go up behind us or it will go
on
i think it's just
accessible through the website through
the website that you will have already
seen right
fine would you like to present your
question please
this hearing is to determine an
application made for the grant of a new
premise license made under section 17 of
the licensing act 2003
by hawley park limited at wood road site
hawley park wood road woolpit
the application was received by the
licensing authority on the 25th of
february 2022 and a copy of this is
attached to this report as appendix a
the application made has been subject to
the statutory consultation period as
prescribed by regulation the notices
advertising the application have been on
display at the premise and published in
the very free press
in their 4th of march 2022 edition
full details of the proposed activities
and timings are contained within the
application form as attached appendix a
the operating schedule steps proposed by
the applicant to promote the four
licensing objectives are attached to
appendix b
a hearing is necessary to determine the
application following receipt of
representations with which have not been
withdrawn the subcommittee will be aware
that its consideration is confined to
the promotion of the four licensing
objectives and the need or commercial
demand for licensed premises are not
consideration
for the licensing authority when
discharging its licensing functions
in carrying out its license and
functions the license and authority must
have regard to its statement of licence
and policy published under section 5 of
the act
and any guidance issued by the secretary
of state under section 182
the license and authority must carry out
its functions under the act with a view
to promoting the licensing objectives
which are the prevention of crime and
disorder public safety
prevention of public nuisance the
protection of children from harm
where revisions are made to the
legislation or guidance issued by the
secretary of state there may be a period
of time when the local statement of
licence and policy is inconsistent with
these revisions in these circumstances
the licensing authority will have regard
and give appropriate way to the relevant
changes guidance and its own statement
of licence and policy
the license authority has not received
any representations from the responsible
authorities under the license in act
2003
further conditions have been agreed by
the applicant on the 17th of march 2022
after mediation with an officer from
babel mid suffolk district council
environmental protection team these are
attached as appendix d
there have been 23 representations
received and made by other persons
which include local residents businesses
and residents associations this is
attached as appendix e to this report
the subcommittee must having regard to
the representations made take such
such of the steps if any as it considers
appropriate for the promotion of the
licensing objectives
and that is to grant the license subject
to conditions which are consistent with
the operating schedule accompanying the
application modified to such an extent
that the authority considers appropriate
for promotion of the licensing
objectives and subject to any mandatory
conditions which must be included in the
license or to exclude from the scope of
the license any licensable activities
to which the application relates to
refuse to specify a person in the
license as a premise supervisor or to
reject the application
any party agreed by the decision taken
by the licensing authority in respect of
this application has a statutory right
of appeal to the magistrate's court that
concludes my summary chair
thank you very much indeed so can i ask
mr williams do you have any questions
for the officer at all
none thank you
and um
julia you do you have any questions no
and tracy kettle any questions for the
officer no
um
councillor flatman do you have any
questions for the officer councillor
muller
no right
and
thank you very much
so mr williams if you would allow light
to present your case
um and uh
we'll hear from you now thank you and if
you press the button and we should be
able to hear you clearly thank you
uh well first of all i i'd like to thank
the um officials and the members of the
of the um committee
uh
for um
this
very um
impressive
hearing
i even feel apologetic
at having caused
our council to spend so much money on
holding this kind of thing i had no idea
when i put in the application that it
would come to this
[Music]
i have absolutely no criticisms
whatsoever of
the
mid suffer gamba licensing department
who've been very cooperative and helpful
but i guess this is
democracy and action
what i do criticize
somewhat is
the
i would say rather clumsy
uh way one has to phrase applications
um
under the 2003 act
the
rules change
for
small events up to 250 they change again
for events up to 500 people
and then they change again
at the 5000 mark
so one is applying for a license for up
to 5000. now
i know
that this site at wood road would never
hold 5000 people
its capacity might be
two and a half perhaps
uh i'd like to illustrate
uh
this kind of these kind of problems um
by explaining how this application came
about
um
hawley park
does not organize events at all
not even weddings
it earns its keep
by
hiring
its
historic and
very nice property
for
events small ones such as weddings in
the barn
larger ones
and we have had
a license for events on the main park
for
quite some time
um
but
we actually only have one
licensable event
on the main park
it's called alive and v dubbin
and it is a camping a three-day camping
event
for vw enthusiasts
to
enjoy
all the things associated with owning a
campervan or a
vw car
um
the most important
part of our income is hawley park barn
which is a successful wedding venue
and of course
has struggled in the last two years
being shot for half the time
but we also
have
quite a number of smaller events
in the uh in the park and on the wood
road site
such as
running events cycling events
small ones and
they are not licensable
activities
we
we have
two large events
in and around the barn and
main house
the
thing called
weird and wonderful wood
which again hasn't happened for the last
two years
but hopes hopefully will be happening
in may
and we have um
an event called spectacle of light in
february
both of these events
um
we don't do weddings in february so
um
the spectacle of light doesn't interfere
with that
um
we do do weddings in um
at the time when um
alive and v dubbing happens
but
it it happens
it is planned
well ahead
earlier
than
the time when people might be booking a
wedding
and
it uses the main entrance to hawley park
on the
old berry road shall we call it
and
that has good access
to both
in both directions to the a14
alive in vwn
is a very
well organized event
that came to us having outgrown jimmy's
farm
and
it started with us in 2017
and
we've had three events it happens in the
main park as far as i know it causes
very little
complaints
and
i converge for the fact that it's well
organized
and
the organizers of alive and vw came to
me and said look we
we have
obviously suffered financially in the
last two years
we would like to hold a fundraising
event
and i said well we won't
very
the barn is very fully booked with
weddings this year
many postponements from last year and
even the year before
[Music]
it would be difficult to find a date
and they said well could we hold it in
wood road
and
on the wood road site it's a site that
they have used as part of their main
event for quiet camping
and
for day visitor parking
non-licensable events or activities
and
i said to them well
it's not licensed
and
i know how important it is to to event
organizers to be running a bar and
having music and so on
and they said okay well we'll get a
license
and
i said well
how much how much is that going to cost
you and they said well it's about 1100
pounds i think
and i said well for a fundraising event
that's a pretty bad start
um
what if we
apply for the license
which then becomes a more permanent
thing
and
i know that
if we apply for a license it costs
around about 180 190 pounds a year
mark
and so
it was on that basis that i went ahead
to
apply for
a license
and
the
problem with the act is that an event
organizer like us applying for a license
does not know
who is going to want to hold an event on
on that piece of land
we don't know the size of the event
um we don't know how many will come
along
so we're working in the dark
and
obviously that means that
you tend to
exaggerate
or apply for the maximum number of
events at different levels that you
could possibly imagine holding on that
site
we asked for
15
now
this is another awkward aspect or clumsy
aspect i think of the act
we asked for 15 event days now that
doesn't mean 15 events
15 event days up to a capacity of 5000
which we can't use anyway
and
the the
the the
an event on an
outside event
um
is likely to be a camping event
as is um
the one they want to hold the
fundraising event they want to hold was
actually is
happening
starting this very day
on wood road site
but without any licensable activities
going on
and with much reduced
participation by the
public by the
campers
so that's an awkward aspect you ask for
as many as you can get um
and
it's really i suppose up to
this meeting and
um
the council parts to pakistan if they
feel they want to
we only have one other event
booked for this year
on the wood road site
and it's by the same organizers who in
july
want to extend their activities
from just bold vw campers to
other makes of classic cars and hold an
event a camping event for classic car
owners in july they want to
try to hold it anyway
they have
already planned out
what their use of the site would be and
they estimate that they have
space for 288
campers
parker
pitch pitches for 288
campers
i suppose there would be perhaps
three or four
people per site so we're talking about
roughly a thousand people there
um
and that actually leaves
enough space for a further
700
places for
day visitors to park
they estimate that in terms of capacity
this site will
never hold an event bigger than that and
it will be somewhere between two and a
half and three thousand
um
we had a visit from the
environmental
sound engineer
who
expressed
basic approval of the um
of the operation subject to
um
certain limits that he wishes to
us to abide by which we will
in addition
we have proposed in our application that
we will always have a phone number at
the entrance to the site
that people can ring if they have any
complaints
only bracken lodge and
farm are within 500 metres of the source
of the sound they are the only houses
they are directly
uh opposite this site on the other side
of wood
road um
they are somewhat protected by the lie
of the land uh which dips down towards
them
and
as far as i
would imagine
the the
living rooms and gardens face the other
way towards the west
uh
the houses in
um
bally green from which we've received
many um
objections
the nearest one is about 650 meters away
um from the source of the sand and the
furthest that is it's over a kilometer
away
um
[Music]
there is a bit of an elephant in this
room
though
this is a licensing inquiry
and
the vast majority of the objections
appear to be on the basis of
traffic nuisance on wood road
i i which i think technically is beyond
the remit of the license hearing
uh although if
maybe comes under public nuisance i
don't know
um
there will be traffic to and from the
site
[Music]
neither the police nor
other agencies involved with roads or
safety have raised any objections to our
application
we have replaced the gate
to
onto wood road which has been there
well for
for probably centuries
um
[Music]
the
uh the gate is a single 12-foot gate
we've replaced it with two 10-foot gates
to create a two-way
access point there
the the actual
um
opening onto the road itself has always
been wide enough for two way
um
and we have also got a long trap
um within the site
towards
where the center of um
any events is likely to be which is
i think you've seen on the map i expect
in the corner formed by the two
wood woodland sides
because that's where water is
and
we can create a queuing lane
of up to 180 meters to avoid any
tail back onto the road
um
our traffic will
will tend to be off peak
um given the fact that
events are likely to be at a weekend
um
we
judging by what alive and v dubbing have
done in the past with traffic that has
entered through that road
they put up notices directing all
traffic
to the right
to go towards
the old berry road
is the
main access to the a14
our traffic is is
most this at least for this event um
mostly coming from
fairly far away
i don't think
many people
will want to go through bali green
and
i do feel
that
we're being
criticized almost
or we're being a victim
of the existing traffic problem on wood
road
which we will only marginally
add to
and at offbeat times
and we're also
potentially
might be a victim
of the condition of wood road
and particularly
warren lane
which
is the straight bit
that um
you you turn in
directly off of
berry road
and it's in very poor condition
i i noticed that they've put up notices
that patching on that road will be
starting on
monday this coming monday
which is a which is a day on which
there will still be some clearance going
on from
the event that they're holding
the unlicensed event that they're
holding
we will allow that clearance
and we can we can allow
a lot of
clearance from wood road
to cross the park and use our main
entrance not the wood road entrance
in my experience the worst thing
on on wood road is the bend
which is blinded
by
a line of trees
the bend where wood road turns into
warren lane
that line of trees is so close to the
road it's not on our land it's on
the roadside verge
and it's
vegetation there as well
and
i would say that i'm very willing to
cooperate with the council
in
trying to improve the sight lines on
that bend
which i find the worst aspect of um
the road
uh i hope
this addresses
some of your concerns i mean we we
basically don't know what's likely to
happen on that road
we don't have a reputation for
raves we are not
um
we were not
what's it called um
latitude
we are not a v festival we won't have
events
where the main event is
or the main object is loud music
um the the nature of the site is
is
peace peace and quiet that's what people
come for and the countryside
so i hope this addresses some of your
concerns
thank you very much
thank you mr williams if you'd like to
turn the thing off i've got several
questions it's not going to be the
spanish inquisition but i do have
several questions myself and my good
colleagues will but one of the most
important ones i've got before we sort
of go down i'll let my colleagues have a
go before i ask all of them
have you had planning permission for
change of use of agricultural or arable
land for these activities
no i don't think i have
it is
um
but it is not agricultural land it was
arable
yeah
i know the area extremely well i used to
live in walpole so i know i know the
area
so um so the answer to that at the
moment is no that might be an issue that
we might have to look at but not
within our guises but you might have to
look at at a later date so i've asked
that question so i'll let my colleagues
ask their questions because i've got a
list of others
by sheik for most of the time
that would be planning to keep the sheep
off it before any event three weeks
before any event
that would be a planning issue that
would have to be addressed possibly yes
and i'll call on my legal advisor yeah
perhaps i could just assist a little bit
there are uh certain permitted
development rights where you can hold so
many events without seeking planning
permission but when you get above a
certain threshold
there may be a requirement for change of
use um through the the planning um
system so it may be something after
today you may want to approach the local
planning authority um to discuss that
yes i mean
unfortunately we can't get that
information here because we don't
necessarily know and it'll be for our
planning colleagues to to advise in that
respect
thank you for that assistance i can just
advise you i am chairman of planning at
mid-suffolk district council so that one
was to my four and what people have to
understand is planning and licensing are
two separate things
so anyway i will ask my colleagues if
they have questions of you and then i
have a few myself that they may well
cover as i say it's not the spanish
inquisition it's just finding
information all right so councillor
flatman do you have a question
you have mentioned that you
move the traffic across to the main
entrance
for monday
is there any um
likelihood that you would be able to do
that when it's a really busy time
uh with the cars leaving to go across
that route at all
just to ease things would it be possible
to do that
on
a
sunday
that weddings happen on a
saturday um
our wedding business is the vastly most
important thing to us
and
we do sell it
the barn on the basis of
exclusivity and the drive through the
park is a is an important part of that
i've heard people say i knew this was
where we'd have our wedding
when we were driving up the park yeah
so thank you very much thank you
see that i've got quite a few questions
um as i said for clarity um
so
um one question have you engaged with
the parish council and the local people
um
before coming here today have you
um
knowing that you've had
this
i
with respect
uh we are a forgotten corner of woolpit
parish we're a little triangle or part
of it
um north of the a14
and judging by
the fact that they have allowed
three very large warehouses to be built
the other side of warren maine
that that's planning and that's that's
not that's not necessarily down to the
parish no but i mean
um
frankly i i'm
i'm not sure woolpid is aware
that we actually have more land in
warpit than we do in any other parish so
at the moment the answer would be we
haven't had that
conversation with them just the woods
are called we'll pick woods yeah yeah
yeah
so so that's fine um
so i've asked that one ask that one
um now each each
person you're saying the vw group that
come along and i mean i know at
helmingham hall they have events up
there with the cars you know they have
the classic cars and things like that so
it's a similar sort of thing that it
looks like you you promote there um
so if the license wasn't granted today
the individuals could still apply for
the license and you would consider
bearing in mind that we might have a
change of use but park that for one
minute you would consider um people
still coming to you should the license
not be approved today you would still
consider letting that facility get their
own license yes
yes yes if they're willing to full cut
1100 pounds yeah that wouldn't be your
issue that would be theirs wouldn't it
yeah so so that's that's something that
we can just
again park if you'll excuse the
vw
um
and um this is sort of a question i i
need to ask but i know the answer to it
but i think the public need to know it
um
you and your family have been there for
many many years um but should you decide
to sell and move on if this permission
were granted we'd have to have a fresh
application and license isn't that
correct um nigel you know if anybody
knew kane because clearly mr williams
saying well we don't want 5000 there so
um no there wouldn't be an actual
a new license there may be a transfer
over to any operator okay may be able to
sort of highlight that
yes chair um a transfer could be
submitted or
on leaving mr williams could surrender
the license in which case a new one
would have to be applied for
saying is that you wouldn't particularly
want to have 5000 there but if the
license says you can and even though the
capacity might not be there you just
don't know what happens to the future
our license needs to be
renewed every three years does it not
no that's not correct you pay an annual
fee it runs concurrent it's just an
annual fee
okay
indeed
so that was that
i'm not sure whether this would have
come within the environmental thing and
that but with all these campers and
everything what are the toilet
facilities
they would provide them
trailer them in and sort of thing yep
lovely thank you
yeah
right
yeah that's fine um and um
hopefully on page 29 appendix d
um you you you said in your submission
there that you will abide by the sound
um restrictions and so on that's quite
difficult sound carries doesn't it so
how would you be able to monitor for
yourself rather than waiting for someone
to ring that number on the gate
there is a sound engineer
who has to test it
and
make sure it stays below the 53
decibel
or whatever it is level yes i'm i'm not
expert in
the numbers there
he gets a bit
excited and turns it up and then
somebody has to go and tell him to turn
it down are you on site will you be
around
well i live on site but i don't live
on wood roads
oh no i understand
okay so there'll be self-regulation plus
of course i have a personal license
yes i realize that yeah
um fine well that's very helpful for me
so now i can ask
um
so first of all i will ask the licensing
officer if you have any further
questions
no
and so i can come to um
the the speakers who
uh may have a question if you like for
mr williams do you have any questions
first of all
are going to be more um for
for you for the for the legalities of
licensing
because i hear what mr williams says
yes this is the problem i hear what mr
williams says but my interest is in if
he says he doesn't want
to hold raves or become latitude
why is he applying
well for certain but he's got he's he's
ticked a lot of boxes about live music
and things he could he could do a very
simple
ticking box saying i i i like the vw
campaign
but it doesn't it doesn't make any sense
you you're having the opportunity to to
make a
do you have any questions at this time i
think what mr williams has just said my
question is is
how
i mean do i get an opportunity to ask
you at the end how mr williams
statements can be put into
into some kind of legal position
what the what the subcommittee will need
to decide
is whether the application as it is made
with the conditions that have been
applied
would be
what would have a detrimental effect on
any of the four licensing objectives
if there is a detrimental effect on any
of the four licensing objectives they
may refuse the application or they may
amend the application they may alter it
they may impose
extra conditions but the only
the condition should only be imposed if
those conditions will prevent those
licensing objectives being impacted on
um
that is the situation we're in now we we
have to work with the application we've
been put before us your representations
and the guidance we're given through the
legislation and through the guidance
thank you so unless you have any
questions like i said you will have an
opportunity to make your statement in a
few minutes
and and may i also ask tracy kettle if
you have any specific questions that you
might like mr williams to answer for you
yes one that
has come up that seems to me to be
relevant is when a hirer comes to you
how much information do you obtain from
them
how they are going to use the site
well
um on a big
event
of the kind for example
the vw people organize
it's a requirement
under our
events license
that the organizer provides what's
called an event management plan emp
with all the details of safety and
we have our own as well because we have
to
make sure that our site is safe
and
these are quite large documents and
quite thorough
sorry
specifically in mind the cycling and the
running that have been happening for
some time
these may not be licensed
specifically no that those wouldn't be
licensable so you have no jurisdiction
no so in the future if events are
licensed as far as amplified sound
you know what these
hirers are going to be using the site
for
well i must say it was news to me
when i read in one of the objections
that there was a tanner used
on that field
and
i was unaware of that i mean these these
running events are
somewhat different from
a sort of
staying event
but um
i i wasn't aware that there was a a
tamily being used which you can
understand is a concern for the
residents that we i will raise the
question with um
with our estate manager who perhaps did
know
we certainly hear the tannoy when
wolfpit's steam rally happens in the
field on the other side of berry road
from us
and
or we used to
that again hasn't happened for a while
but that can be annoying
sorry justin thank you any further
questions as such from what you've heard
from mr williams
no
that's fine
um right thank you very much for that
we now
please from the parish council if you'd
like to present your case and issues
please thank you thank you very much
um thank you for inviting me to speak
today um i am chair of the woolpit
parish council
i'm sorry mr williams feels that the
parish council ignores him but he
ignores us so
um
we
have um
a fairly
um good
track record of objecting to the
developments at lawn farm and such like
so
and i wish we were the planning
body that made the decisions because
things would be very different in the
village
under planning applications we are a
statutory consultant but we are not for
licensing and this has been very
disappointing in this case
because if this application is
successful it will have serious
implications
for the parish and in particular for the
residents of bali green
you have received 23 objections i
believe to this application including
those from the parish council
and the district councillors
all the objections refer to the same
concerns of public safety due to traffic
and public nuisance especially due to
noise
mrs cattle who lives closest to the site
will be able to tell you firsthand
of the nuisances from the current use of
the site
and how she and her neighbours will be
affected
if these proposals go ahead
up to 45 days of events most of which
will be at weekends
takes away from neighboring properties
their right to enjoy their own homes
mr williams has said that their
living rooms and gardens are at the
backs of their properties and won't be
affected believe me mr williams events
on your site can be heard in one house
and shelland
not just a few hundred yards away in
brawley green
the
um
add to this
light pollution traffic noise traffic
fumes litter and and to the general
hubbub um that we already have from the
a14
um life will become intolerable
by its own admission the applicant seeks
to protect its wedding business
at the main site
by
moving the disturbances that will arise
from
events taking place
um down to this
what they're calling the wood road site
and therefore on to local residents
in terms of traffic wood road and warren
lane are already the subject of
investigation by highways championed by
our county councillor
at a huge number of vehicles
attending events
and the use of the road will just become
impossible
i appreciate that the licensing
regulations
seek
to regulate the licensed premises
and what happens on public roads
adjacent to the site
may not be under your control
but i urge you
as you say in your own notes to take a
holistic approach
the proposed route on wood road is
unsustainable
it's unsuitable to take additional
volumes of traffic the road is narrow
and
has
been severely damaged but by what i
understand by traffic engineers is
called haunching
where vehicles um
actually put two wheels onto the verge
there are potholes tight and tight
corners
i was very alarmed to see that mr
williams thinks that we should be
chopping down trees just to accommodate
his um his proposals
whatever is promised
there will be queueing traffic for lot
if there are large
events i urge you
not
to grant this application
now
sometimes when i appear before the
planning
committee there is discussion about
if you were minded
to to grant consent what
might
be acceptable
there is very little here that is
acceptable but i would emphasize this
has already been
mentioned by your by
other councillors
that the access should be through hawley
park
main entrance and not off wood road
i
know more than mr williams understand um
all this description of decibels and
hurts and various
things but
i think you will find from the
experiences of local residents that
it is very difficult to abate noise and
what is acceptable to a sound engineer
used to working in that
in in that industry is not acceptable
in the british countryside
and i would also urge that if you were
minded to
to grant a license that it would be for
a very limited number of days
thank you
thank you very much indeed
um can i ask my fellow councillors if
you have any questions for mrs ewan
no and the officers do you have any
questions oh thank you chair
no thank you and mr williams do you have
any questions for the parish council
you might want to make a statement but
that's not a question so um could you if
you have a question you're more than
welcome and
um
i slightly resent
her remarks about um companies
you will have an opportunity to sum up
at the end if you want to make any final
comments to
to address anything we plant an awful
lot of trees
so thank you miss young for um your
presentation there
i now move on to
your colleague tracy kettle if you would
like to present your case please thank
you
yes thank you very much and
you have already said that you've read
the 23 objections and they've been taken
into account so
as one of the two residents office at
hawley park myself and joss and our
neighbors trevor and emma jackson at
bracken lodge
we share the west side border of the
hawley park road site excuse me a minute
can we just
i can't quite hear that
oh could you speak up a little perhaps
if you move the microphone towards you
it is quite difficult we end up sort of
shouting at it because we're used to it
so could you speak up thank you i can
bracken lodge is not shown on the map
that we were given
but for those that don't know it is
opposite the site entrance
the wood road site has no natural tree
line or barrier on the western boundary
so both our houses have an unopposed
view to the north and eastern tree line
very attractive until we have 45
functions per year with nothing to
absorb or deflect noise
and the land may become a car park or a
campsite
the northern boundary is flat to
where the car track will be and the
performance area at the top north east
corner furthest from wood road
the line of sight from bracken lodge is
unopposed at ground level and hence
at first floor level
lock farm looks towards the performance
area from a slightly different angle but
still faces directly into the northeast
corner
there is nothing to deaden or soften the
noise or the light in the vast open area
the controls imposed by environmental
and licensing authorities will not have
as good an outcome as might be possible
with an enclosed property
noise from the 24 acre site will be
uncontrollable
it will also be directly affected by
weather conditions and wind direction
any complaints of noise are to be logged
by the site or the event organizer which
does not stop us having to endure the
noise levels and as julia referred
we have no idea what 53 decibels is
it can sound dreadful it can
how do we know
we do not have sand measuring equipment
and after the event will be unable to
prove levels with certainty
the attractive line of trees forming a
right angled northern eastern barrier
will become a deflector of the noise
emanating from functions
held on the wood road site
we are in a rural area and have doors
and windows open on summer nights and
evenings will this continue when we have
45 functions mostly in the summer and
mostly with amplified noise
i acknowledge the comments that mr
williams has made regarding the
cumbersome nature of the application
and having to apply for more than
necessary
in order to achieve a as hawley park
wishes but once in place
the license stands and evolution and
development of the events
will be well with outside well outside
of our control
also acknowledge that at the moment you
are
involved with the hawley park limited
but as a limited company holding the
license
that is not going to just be you so we
are at the mercy of whoever chooses to
develop the business
and it's that uh
it's that evolution
that is a concern and as i
wanted to mention before but couldn't
the
the running and the cycling events
were exactly that there were stakes and
there was tracks marked out and
a few cars came apart and sometimes
quite a few they ran they they raced
they did what they did and they went
home but that has evolved clearly
without your knowledge into a tannoy
system
of commenting on the race and the
starters and the success
and as soon as that tanay finishes there
is amplified music
as is the case in a lot of american or
now british athletics meetings so that
is already happening but we tolerate
that because they're few and far between
but that has given us great cause to be
concerned that should this license allow
45 functions per year
we will have so little control of what
happens
that sort of thing may indicate what is
going to happen in the future
and that noise is directly into our
house at the moment cycling and racing
occur mostly in the mornings weekday
weekend mornings people are in and
they're out but
the events could be longer
so it wasn't the question sorry
um
what starts as tolerable
will so easily become intolerable and
once this license is in place
we have very little recourse
if this licence is granted it will have
a great effect on
our two houses peaceful enjoyment and as
you can see
the 23 objections of
residents slightly further away but
nonetheless eat nonetheless equally as
disturbed as we are
i noticed at the start of this that
you referred to
documents to be submitted
is it permissible for me to give you
some photographs no
i'm sorry i didn't know that
the um
the drive at bracken lodge
is
12 of my little short paces
from the drive of hawley park
and i parked my car
in the drive of hawley park
and
straight and it's looking directly onto
bracken lodge
now any vehicles exiting
that site at night
during the day for noise but at night
are going to shine their lights on that
house
vehicles turning right vehicles turning
left
the bracken lodge is going to be
severely affected
quite a few of these functions have the
possibility of going to 11 30 and
sometimes to midnight
with an hour two acres of the site
that's a long time for the most
successful events which
may or may not happen or may be
developed that's a long time for that
noise and light to be endured by the
residents of bracken lodge
the
light pollution from the performance
area because the nature of it's
completely open because the nature of
the site
the tree line
north and east
will absorb
will absorb nothing to do with light the
light will be there and this morning or
early as this morning when it was still
dark my curtains are open
my first floor window faces
hawley park with a very nice view right
the way through to what will be the
performance area shown on the map
if the light will be pulsing off my
walls
it doesn't have to be shown into my
windows to be a nuisance
so there's likely to be
with live music
strobe lights flashing stage lights
flood lights lights from vehicles etc
etc
that will be in my window and it clearly
will be in bracken lodge's window as
well
we are a rural area and we do not need
blackout blinds we certainly don't have
to have our curtains shut we are not
overlooked but this could have a great
effect on how we live our lives
also
on your map or on your submissions
there's no designated area where parking
or camping will or will not be
which i presume means that we are a you
are able to have that as
each hirer chooses to
the road between loch farm and the site
are six paces my little short legs
if camping or parking is opposite us
as has been the case
for a few daytime events where cars have
been parked the other side of the road
we will have people noise car noise and
headlights in our windows potentially
anytime up to 1am there is no
restriction
in any of this on that
there is no
nobody has paid heed to these two
properties that face you
the attendees are there to enjoy their
time and not respect
our peace we don't expect that of them
but they should not be near enough or
indeed even ever be there because it's
too close
assuming some degree of proportion on
the map provided
our two houses
are three to four times closer
to the hatched marquee tents performance
area
than the current site of alive and
dubbin are to the barn
the alive and dublin along the road from
the main entrance
three to four times closer
how is that fair
with no consideration of our properties
the quiet enjoyment of our properties
overlooking hawley park will be taken
away if this licence is granted
45 occasions per year mostly in the
summer potentially any of the seven days
per week up to midnight
bank holidays in new year's eve for all
categories of function
granting this license will be
detrimental to our lives
there are vast expanses of land
on hawley park
the management of which is none of my
business
but surely
there's a better way to use your land
rather than
move
the concerns that you have that this
new arm of your business will be
detrimental to yourselves you have moved
that concern to the two properties
opposite you
and
the people on wood road and
warren lane and down to bali green we
will all be affected by this and it is
just
not acceptable so i really do urge that
this license is not granted
thank you very much indeed that was very
helpful and very full thank you
can i ask my
officers do you have any questions
counselor muller
okay
thank
mr williams do you have a specific
question you may sum up at the end of
your views etc but do you have a
specific question
for mrs kettle
no because you you will just have the
opportunity very shortly to sum up in
fact
now then um
normally what happens in a meeting such
as this is we have um the specified
speakers
and i am aware of the locale and the um
i have
made an analysis of all the points that
people have made representations of and
a lot of it is traffic and noise
[Music]
on on the things that have come to us to
look at
um and um i spoke with the legal officer
and um
he's asked me to
allow
if there are any points that haven't
been raised
by anybody to the members of the public
who are sitting here it's quite out of
the ordinary to do this but are there
any points that haven't been raised or
covered that you feel you would like to
make a point on so i've got the three
main ones the noise traffic and light
pollution
um plus of course the
finer details as provided by the the two
ladies here so is that anybody who feels
there's anything missing from
your speakers
i will allow you um a minute or so just
to make you can't just clarify chair
that that's anything that you've already
put in your written representations so
something that's been put in your
written representations that you feel
has not been highlighted so it's not an
opportunity to bring up something new
um it's just something that you feel may
not have been
elaborated on sufficiently
i'll give you a few minutes to think
yes could you make your name please yes
my name is robin white
i
live in uh the oaks in bowling green
i have made a representation yes
um there's nothing mentioned about
nature
there is a um a herd of red deer in bali
green in wood what's it what what is
that
wood
um
i'm sure the noise pollution would
affect that they um they often walk
across the road into adjacent fields to
graze and then come back again
i'm sure the noise pollution and light
pollution would affect their
their way of life
also
when you've got vast amount of well i'll
say last large amount of cars moving
down that road at night
the deer will walk across the road
they'll just move on
that's a good point made and i've made a
note of that when we go into private
session we'll include that in our
discussions
yeah
thank you
you can let
that move forward right so thank you
very much indeed
um
so
providing it's in your paper
yep please
yeah my name is martian wood i live in
the oaks pawley green
um it's a question around who has the
responsibility for ensuring that the
maximum number of events per annum
doesn't exceed
any
uh
uh any any part of the license if it's
if it's if it's if it's um given and
in the same vein who has responsibility
for monitoring and ensuring the
amplified music levels are in line with
any specified limit can you answer on
that one
we are
limited to
um
the the general public raising concerns
in certain aspects that there are
certain enforcement powers that that
officers can carry out to monitor
generally speaking um it's
brought to the council's attention by by
the general public when um things are
not being complied with particularly
noise and issues like that
um so what was the the second part of
your
as well yes i mean
the number of events will will will be
monitored um
again i'm sure if
you know
records will be kept by by the the local
public um if they feel that they're
exceeding and that will be investigated
they are required to um carry out and
inform the local authority when they're
having these events through the um the
management plan so i believe it's one of
the conditions is that to mid suffocate
no they took to the licensing authority
that would be mid-mid
yeah
um yeah with regard to the actual
monitoring of the noise um specified
that they have to have
checks by qualified engineers when
they're setting up this equipment as
well in accordance with the conditions
okay
if it's already in your papers and
you've it hasn't been covered but we
must we mustn't make two
but
well it hasn't been covered but um
wood road and warren lane are a
designated cycle route
[Applause]
is it
i just put it down to safety
thank you for that
right so do we have any questions
members do we have any further questions
for anyone
officers no
right so it now comes to the closing
submission
we have the licensing officer to give a
closing statement
and then i will ask the applicant to
close you always have the final say
before we go into private session so
okay anything no i haven't come further
thank you so mr williams it's over to
you to sum up and give us your final
thoughts on this please so that we can
then go off into session
well i've explained that in actual fact
we only have one event
this year booked
the
fact that we've applied for
uh
is it 30 event days
for
the smaller events and 15 event days for
the larger events
and even the larger events not likely to
be more than
of
attendance of
of about two and a half thousand
these are going to be small events
mostly
and
there will not be many of them there
certainly won't be 45
days of the year occupied
with events
um
bali green is a long way away and i'm
very surprised you can even hear us
there's an awful lot of woodland between
us and you
that must absorb some of the sound
loke farm is much closer
obviously
but
unless i'm much mistaken
you are
quite a considerably lower level
than
the bank
on our side of the road i'm very
surprised you can actually see
over that
and
bracken lodge is i've stood in front of
bracken lodge i've looked uh towards
where the marquis would be in that
corner of the site which is surrounded
by woods
and i reckon i could probably see the
top of the marquee but not
not the the first like
seven foot of it or so
um
the the uh
the traffic well
as i say that's not a strip not strictly
for this
particular inquiry
but
i've explained that we
we have had events on that site and
we do direct traffic towards
the old berry road
um
the um
the e the quickest way anyway from that
site entrance to the a14
even by satnav i would imagine it's via
warren lane into elmswell
and to j
47
but as i say
this
application um
makes things look
an awful lot more alarming
than i believe they really will be
and uh
well the entrance has been there
probably
long before
most of the houses were built
um
in fact
in fact the houses on which most of
those warren
those bally greenhouses
were built is on
land
um
[Music]
the
um
the gamekeeper
inherited from a previous owner of
hawley park
and um
was
lucky enough to
manage to get a lot of housing
development on it
i think
the important thing perhaps to say is
that
hawley park
as i said at the beginning
it has nothing
other than
the assets that are present on this site
it has no agricultural
holding like
you know
two centuries ago i think the estate was
2 000 acres or something
this is the historic
core
of a very significant
site
a grade one listed
has
which takes an awful lot of
upkeep
a grade two listed barn
and
we have to struggle to
earn enough money from our assets that
we do have
to do that and it's been extremely
difficult i mean
we're we are surviving now
because i've raided the building's fund
if you like
to keep
to keep hawley park limited
afloat
although i do have to say that
the rates rebate from mid suffolk
district council and the government
grants
have been very
helpful as well
so
i i think that's all i have to say i
hope that
this will be allowed
i'm prepared for numbers to be cut down
if you wish
to do that because i don't i do believe
that i have
maybe over stated
our requirement
but it's very similar to our requirement
on the main park
and i urge the
council to
approve
this application
thank you very much indeed
so i think we've all had sufficient time
and the applicant is always last to to
present the case but i must put forward
this following motion on the basis that
the subcommittee considers that the
public interest in excluding the public
outweighs the public interest in its
deliberation being held in public
it is resolved that under section 100a
brackets iv of the local government act
1972 the public be excluded from the
meeting on the grounds that it involves
likely disclosure of exempt information
as defined in part one of schedule 12 of
the act
on the ground set out in the regulation
14 brackets 2 of the licensing act 2003
brackets hearings
regulations 2005.
may i have a proposal and a secondary to
the motion
thank you councilman thank you
councillor flatman so the livestream
will now be paused and ourselves we will
disappear you will not where there's too
many of you to to hide you
so we will now go out into private
session thank you very much indeed
and the officer
well thank you very much for your
patience and welcome back
um we have come to a decision um and
there's quite a lot involved in it so
i'm going to ask nigel to advise what
the outcome is thank you very much
thank you chair
the subcommittee have listened to all
the representations and read all the
written representations and have
considered
the impacts on the immunity of the local
residents and local wildlife and have
noted all those concerns
they also note that
the subcommittee acknowledges that the
applicant's desire and needs to utilize
his property to to operate his business
to to its best potential
within
the legislation set out under the four
licensing objectives
and the decision is is that a license
will be granted
but it will be modified to such an
extent as the license field that the
subcommittee feels it mitigates the
concerns
the two licensing objectives that they
considered and that were put before them
really today were the
the public safety aspects we like
resulting from the use
of the local roads and also the uh the
public nuisance from the the noise and
the light pollutions
i'll just touch on the the traffic
concerns
and the public safety aspect first
government guidance states that licence
holders have a responsibility to ensure
the safety of those using the premises
access to the site is by public
maintainable highway and it's and the
applicant has a reasonable expectation
to utilize those roads for his business
also it is a matter for individuals to
take personal responsibility for their
behaviour when they're away from the
licensed premises so the the um
the public safety aspect
according to following the government
guideline guidance
really relates to the public safety
using the premises
that's not to say that there isn't an
issue with the public safety of
accessing and leaving the premises
and the procedures in place but the the
subcommittee on this occasion have felt
that that's not a reason to
refuse the the application
moving on to
public nuisance um and firstly the the
issue of noise
the subcommittee notes that the
environmental protection team have
agreed conditions
uh relating to noise noise limits
but there is still a concern that there
will be disturbance caused to the local
residents particularly the closest
dwellings
and therefore
the timing of all licensable activities
will end at 11 pm
the seasonal variation for new year's
eve to midnight is approved but the
other seasonal variations
are not
there also with regard to
light pollution
um
there is a going to be a prohibition on
the use of fireworks um to limit the
impact of
noise and disturbance uh to the local
residents and to the local wildlife
and a further condition prohibiting the
use of all laser lighting and strobe
lighting at any event
other conditions have been amended
in particular
condition 2.5 which refers to the
maximum number of large outdoor events
that is to be reduced from 15 down to 5
with a maximum attendance of
2500
and the maximum number of medium outdoor
events will be reduced from 30 to 15
and these reductions are
are made in indiana to reduce the uh the
public nuisance and the frequency of of
those potential events causing that
that's that nuisance
on section on condition 2.10
which states that the the premises
license holder shall ensure that all
larger and medium event organizers or
premises users
prepare and operate a suitable and
sufficient event management plan
that copies of those will be provided to
the local authority
and those will be obviously provided
before the events take place
and it's also noted that there is um for
the larger event an event management
plan will also be provided to the local
authority beforehand i think four months
ahead
was it two months i can't
so two two months so that was condition
2.14 which is acknowledged and that's
not altered but i'm just highlighting
that that there is a condition that the
local licensing authority will need to
approve the event management plans for
those events
so that is i believe i've covered
everything
thank you there is a right of appeal
anyone who's made an application or a
representation to
the licensing authority has a right of
appeal against the decision or against
any conditional restriction applied by
the local licensing authority
an appeal should be made to the
magistrates court within 21 days of
receiving written notification of the
council's decision i will now hand back
to the the chair who has a few comments
to make
thank you very much indeed um
as a subcommittee we are limited to the
full licensing objectives and the one
that we've looked at in detail is the
public nuisance and have adjusted the
permissions accordingly
we might also encourage the use of the
main entrance for vehicles where
possible
we can only ask
i know this isn't the outcome for either
side and although not a licensing issue
planning permission for erection of
marquis change of use of land the exit
may be needed
and should be pursued and any highways
issues may be addressed at that time
can i also add
that the license can be reviewed at any
time if necessary
so it's been very difficult for us and
that is the decision that we've made
today my words are informative thank you
very much for your attendant and your
input today everybody thank you the
meeting is now closed
thank you